alright time once again for our movie
retrospective show yeah this time we're
going back to the 70s once again doing
the Stepford Wives yeah this is an old
classic I remember growing up as a kid
this one was mentioned a lot it was kind
of kind of a part of 70s and 80s culture
well even today I think everybody knows
that concept you know to me which is
kind of amazing because you know it
didn't do like it did kind of like well
at the box office back in the 1970s but
it seems like it's cultural impacts
really you know kind of like outsides
like an outsized thing of its you know
yeah kind of had a similar impact this
say like The Exorcist or Salem's Lot or
you know it was just part of the
zeitgeist at the time oh yeah definitely
and like I said even people who haven't
seen the original movie use technology
if you say like separate wife everybody
knows what you mean which is kind of
amazing in a way if you haven't seen
this one it's free on YouTube right now
yeah for now until although it's been up
there for a while there's like a really
good channel I can't remember what the
channel is called but he has like all
kinds of like really cool 70s and 80s
like TV movies and like just old kind of
Forgotten horror movies he's got all
kind of good [ __ ] on it it's kind of
like a science fiction movie along the
lines of West world in a certain way but
it's more more sinister kinda like
Rosemary's Baby same author yeah same
author
yeah it's dudes replacing their wives
with perfect robots yeah robot
artificial robot of their wife kind of a
social commentary of the day oh yeah
definitely yeah it's pretty good movie
yeah it's it's interesting because the
the movie is very much it's pretty much
the textbook definition of a slow burn
but that was what I liked about it and
they did a remake of it in 2004 and I'll
talk about that in a little bit that was
horrible
but um the thing I liked about this one
is that it really kind of took its time
and the [ __ ] that happens like after
they moved to Stepford it's just very
very subtle so it's almost kind of like
you think maybe she's being paranoid now
like I said this is
that movie came out 1975 and it was
based on the novel or actually I guess
it was in novella cuz it was kind of
short the separate wise by Ira Levin he
was also the guy that we're at
Rosemary's Baby and this has a very
similar vibe of like a woman who's like
at the center of this conspiracy and
everyone is telling her that she's crazy
and that what she's perceiving is not
correct so it's very similar kind of
theme to that so I guess I were 11 kind
of gave her a kiss before dying too
which was awesome but I can't remember
if the theme to that was similar but he
was like really good at doing these kind
of like satirical cuz this is a
satirical horror but it is pretty creepy
too yes guy takes his wife into this new
community called step called Stepford
yeah it's in Connecticut it's in connect
they're from New York City yeah and you
know they just she's checking out the
neighbors and you know and it's just
like the neighbors these guys are all
rich and they got these perfect wives
you know they're real hot you know the
dudes are not that hot yeah they're all
like schlubby kinda yeah and but she the
actress strange you know they're always
they're the perfect homemakers there's
like little little episodes of guys
trying to make moves on other guys wives
it's weird because she's watching them
from afar she doesn't really know what
the hell's going on and I think I think
the husband doesn't quite know what's
going on till they've been there for a
while now here's something that cuz I do
I hadn't seen I mean I watch this movie
again like I've seen it like a whole
bunch of times but I hadn't seen it for
several years so I watched it again a
few days ago for this review and one
aspect of it that I hadn't remembered
was that shortly after moving to
Stepford the husband has like a very
weird like exchange with the guy that
lives across the street from them like
they're both out by their mailbox like
getting their mail or something and he
says to the neighbor that because the
the neighbor lady had like brought them
a casserole when they first moved in and
he says to the other guy he says
something like she looks as good as she
cooks or something like that which led
me to believe that he knew about the
whole swapping our wives with sexbots
thing before he moved there and that was
why he moved there
because you find out later on I mean the
main character Joanna Eberhart who's
played by Katharine Ross and she is like
really really great in this but um you
know she was from New York City she was
like a photographer she's trying to
break into light photography trying to
take her suffer in the galleries and
stuff like that it kind of comes to
light later on with a argument that
she's having with her husband Walter
that she did not really want to move to
Stepford I mean he basically made the
decision without really consulting her
because she says to him at one point
she's like you know it's like you talked
about moving here and you had already
been looking at houses she's like you
know we came to look at this house and
you would already put a down payment on
it so he kind of like railroaded her
into moving because she's like a big
city girl and she didn't really not want
to move to this like weirdest suburb but
she's kind of like going along with it
you know it'll be safer for the kids and
blood yeah I guess you're right he would
have had to have known what the place
was that's what I mean anyways like it
was a lot like if you guys ever saw
Westworld yeah it's like an amusement
park but it's an exact replica of a
perfect suburban upper-class
neighborhood yeah but it blends in with
the rest of America nobody knows that
this is like a theme park and all these
guys have this packed when they show up
there
they eventually kill the wife yeah her
place are with one of these it's like a
sexbot yeah a robot pretty much it also
click and it's pretty weird it's weirder
for the day because people really
weren't real familiar with the idea of
AI and the whole idea of a sex bob I
think was kind of rare back in those
days nowadays they got dam companies
that'll sell you a sexbot that you know
I mean it doesn't walk yeah they got the
thing where it'll talk and it'll hook up
to Siri yeah I don't understand it you
know they were they were on it they got
this woman brought one on to a talk show
just the other day I was with
what's-his-name guy to get he does the
big pot joe rogan this woman brings us a
replica sex pot of herself on a Joe
Rogan and it was talking yeah it was
talking but it's talking through Siri
and a special probe
gram but you know this is going on now
so I think modern people really this
does not have the same impact on yeah
it's I mean obviously it's gonna have it
had a much bigger impact in the 70s
because that was still like kind of a
novel concept and taboos is subjective
got what well not so much because the
whole the guy who runs Stepford Dale
Koba used to work for Disney meaning
that he like built like in the Hall of
Presidents where they have like those
animatronic people yeah so like he was
and all of his little circle of friends
are also like scientists and engineers
and artists and stuff like that so
they're all kind of like in on this
conspiracy yeah and it makes you wonder
I mean is this thing growing do they
plan on just revenge replacing all the
women with these robots see I don't
really know is it gross because they
were bringing guys it was almost like a
cult yes I said it
you know agree to this and they can't
kept his secret and it didn't happen
like it didn't happen immediately it's
like usually it was after I think that
at one point like near the end where
Katherine Ross's character goes to like
an analyst because she's not sure if
she's right about her suspicions about
the conspiracy which she is foiler alert
or she's going crazy like her husband
made her go to a therapist because he's
like oh you're crazy even though he
knows perfectly what's going on but I
think she said that it had been four
months because what ends up happening is
that I mean she moves to this town and
it's just it's just little little things
like that are just off they seem very
off like the women seem kind of like
super vapid it's like they're super
jazzed about like cleaning products all
their houses are spotless they always
look perfect like that wearing aprons
yeah they always have a presume cleaver
they always have high heels like perfect
makeup like even when they're just like
walking around the groceries yeah and
then once they get replaced of course
the the personality is totally changed
yes woman's friends start getting
replaced and you know I'm sudden they're
only interested in housework and that's
one of the creepiest things because when
she first moves there there are actually
a couple of women that haven't been
there long enough to have been replaced
yet so they're still like fairly normal
so she ends up meeting this one woman
named Bobby who is actually like a
really cool character and like the two
of them become four
because they're like what the [ __ ] like
everything is so weird around here and
why are all the women such weirdos and
so those two like kind of bond over this
stuff and they both feel like something
really bad is going on and then they
make friends with this other woman who
is played by the same woman that played
ginger on Gilligan's Island that read
Tina Louise yeah yeah and you know so
she comes to likes it because they're
trying to set up because they're you
know it's the 70s they're very like you
know into feminism and stuff so they're
trying to set up like a feminism group
because you know the men's club they
have their club and no women are allowed
yeah that goes over like a [ __ ] farm
two spaces right and it's like well they
don't realize that I mean this is pretty
early on so they don't realize that most
of them are robots in that most of them
are robots so it's like they have this
meeting and it's like no one has any
questions and like then suddenly like
one of them starts talking about some
starts like some spray starch or
something and she gets like all orgasmic
about it like she's in a commercial yeah
yeah television commercials right so
well they were saying don't you guys
have any complaints and complaints about
housework and their tongue out yeah
saving time and then the next thing you
know they yeah and they're talking about
that all the robots are talking about
what products save the most time and
which is something I think a robot might
well yeah because that's their only
concern their only concern is saving
saving time doing the job they were
cited is serving their husbands yeah I
mean that's all they're supposed to do
and there's actually a very funny scene
in there too where when Bobby and Joanna
are going around trying to like you know
shanghaied women into this feminist
meeting that they're doing and they kind
of like wander into this one house yeah
this was a great scene and she and they
can hear like I'm having sex upstairs
and the woman is just going totally over
the top she's all in the king the
championship like it she's like
screaming yeah yeah and then like later
on like you've kind of forgotten about
that scene but then later on they're in
like the pharmacy or something or like
in the yeah and the pharmacy and like
Bobby says you know and says look over
it look at that guy over there and it's
just a schlubby like it's dude with
glasses like that's Frank you're the
champ Frank yeah yeah yeah right that's
it and it's like he has like this
superhot wife but he looks like Jays
nothing yeah
this schlubby grape well you know it
makes sense you know when when you look
at it from twenty to twenty first
century eyes yeah that's exactly the way
damn store-bought sexbot would be yeah
yeah I mean he's gonna have settings is
very fun and like I said this this is
much more a satirical drama its
satirical but it is a horror movie I
mean it is very creepy particularly at
the end after Bobby gets turned into a
sex pot you know ginger gets turned into
a sex pot I think Bobby getting turned
into a sex pot is the creepiest because
Joanna is like you know that was her
only friend like the only normal person
left and Stepford that she could talk to
and then she goes over to the woman's
house and the woman suddenly got this
long dress on she's got bigger tits
you've got like a different yeah the
other thing of course when when they
replaced these wives they improved them
too yeah they had big old asses on him
big tits and ass and every how they were
walk yeah and with the swish and [ __ ]
yeah yeah that's exactly in the and they
did that and I think the movie kind of
came from a point to where in a place of
time where there was like a culture
clash going on you had guys who maybe
we're probably you know complaining
about the way women were acting in the
70s because these are now these new
liberated women they were probably kind
of complaining in in the in the normal
you know openly kind of in public wild
talk shows and [ __ ] like that that these
women or kana not not as good as they
were probably like in the 50s yes they
weren't they're not doing what we tell
them
there was like damn culture class and I
think they were and I think it was the
movie was kind of a satire on that well
it was these dudes are gonna replace
these women with damn robots that act
just like June Cleaver yeah well I mean
that was the whole Jim Cleaver crossbred
with a porn star yeah yeah yeah I mean
that's of what Ira Levin wrote it is he
wrote it as a satire the weird thing to
me though is that when this movie came
out you know I'm thinking about that's
scary that might happen yeah that might
happen with the technology when
dude stop marrying women or stop dating
women they just instead of buying cars
they just buy these damn AI sexbots I'm
not worried about it yeah I mean yeah
well one less man for me to clean up
don't clean up after me I'm just saying
it's like you know yeah yeah but
thinners what about the human race
though there's no children being born
yeah
well then had to what make test-tube
babies to make sure that kids are born
yeah I guess I could probably years but
yeah so the interesting thing about it
is that when this movie came out there
was a little there was a small like
vocal contingent of people that thought
that it was anti-feminist like it was
making fun of feminists and I'm like if
anything it's making fun of the men that
were threatened by the feminists because
the men were the bad guys I mean the man
that murdered all their we murdered all
their wives and replace them I mean the
whole point of the movie is that's what
the men wanted they wanted yeah we very
clear it was those men well yeah yeah
yeah yeah might interpret what you're
saying is no no all the men I'm just
saying that the man doesn't make that
particular group of guys they've been in
this movie were the bad guys so I don't
really see how anyone could read it as
like making fun of the feminists because
they were the hero that I mean Joanna's
character was the one that you
sympathize with and you were scared for
her and her kids and stuff like that
because you know that this whole like
conspiracy was like closing in around
her well look here's the problem with
the movie the movie didn't age too well
because these so called feminist women
in this movie weren't feminist by
today's standards they're just normal
women
well I'm Donovan well that's what I mean
that's they were just kind of normal
women they'd be the normal women that
you'd find today well yeah just what
gen-x women they had well they had jobs
and they had careers and interests like
outside of the home and it's like even
in the 50s I don't think women were like
they were portrayed in this movie
obviously it's like women have always
been just like normal human being but
that that was kind of like the point of
this at I've mentioned it before you
know my grandmother you know she would
kind of laugh you know when I go visit
her to Mississippi mud my grandmother my
dad you know down in Mississippi I'd sit
there and watch television when I was a
kid you know you're watching Beverly
Hills
Billy's and all these old sitcoms from
the 50s and she just laughed people
weren't like that no they never yeah and
she told me that you know and she was
from that generation she said most women
worked they did have jobs they did and
that they basically did the same thing
that I mean you had to yeah yeah there
was they still needed two incomes back
then yeah I mean depending if you were
like working-class or right yes working
people and middle class people to a
certain extent yeah because the new the
new version of the middle class really
was a thing of the seventies yeah late
70s early 80s you know it was kind of
like the beginning of the yuppies yeah
and I didn't exist you then right it's
like I you know it's I think like a lot
of families just despite what they
showed on like 50s sitcoms a lot of
families couldn't afford yeah that was
oh just have the man work and support
yeah a bunch of kids that happened
because of world war ii while these guys
coming back from from the war and the
government and the military had
basically had merged with hollywood and
that was all government propaganda they
were trying to get guys coming back from
the war like normal and normalized and
integrate and to make this new middle
class that they were envisioning and
they were gonna make them the workers in
these car factories and then it was
gonna be suburbs and it did happen it
just didn't last long
yeah 30 years maybe yeah it started to
break down but yeah 30 40 years the
thing about this movie though it's it's
actually pretty similar to the novel
which I read a long time ago um the
movie was directed by Bryan Forbes who
also ooh go check out seance on a wet
afternoon at the same director and that
is a really really awesome movie
somebody turned it on turned me on to it
like several years ago and I was like
how could I never see this now the
screenplay for this was actually written
by it William Goldman who many people
will know as the writer of The Princess
Bride all the President's Men marathon
man all his stuff like that now
apparently William Goldman had a way
darker ending for this movie and of
ending for this movie is pretty dark I
mean you spoiler alert but Joanna gets
Stepford eyes she doesn't escape you
know yeah and what's weird it's implied
that they used the female robbed robots
to kill the wife they feel that what
guys don't
do it well yeah because they wouldn't
want to get their hands - no they just
tell the other robots they just tell the
robot to do it so that's actually one of
the best scenes like there's a like a
really long extended sequence where you
know Joanna has figured out what's going
on and that you know the the men are
turning the women into sex BOTS and she
goes to like the men's club which is
this big creepy mansion because her
children have been taken there and she
wants to go rescue them and get the [ __ ]
out of Dodge um also she cracks her
husband in the head they don't even plot
they don't say whether he died or not I
mean he probably survived that but she
does crack his skull with a fireplace
poker so she goes to this creepy ass
place and she runs into you know the guy
that worked at Disney the guy that runs
everything and the guy that builds all
the robots presumably Dale Koba and then
she steps into this one but while she's
trying to run away from him and she
steps into this one room that is like
almost a perfect replica of her and her
husband's bedroom at home which they
built to like train the robot I guess to
like walk around in there and yeah you
know how the conceptualization of how AI
is is not really quite cool like I said
it's a long time ago and plus it's a
satire it's not like an art science
fiction so it's like you know anything
that kind of gets the plot going and
it's super creepy - because she walks in
on her on her robot replica but it's not
finished yet and like the eyes are all
black and she is like big way bigger
titties yeah like you can kind of just
see through kind of things yeah to me it
was kind of like Westworld
and yeah if you guys ever seen Westworld
you know Yul Brenner kind of plays the
original terminator but they were doing
that to them when it came time to kill
for the robots to kill a woman you know
I mean they kind of went Terminator
their eyes would go black and stuff it's
pretty cool although yeah I mean like in
Stepford Wives her eyes were black
because she wasn't done yet cuz cuz he
said oh you came a little bit early we
actually weren't done with you oh I was
like the whole conversation that's the
only that's the only thing that they
ever show you of that they're never I
don't did no they didn't ever show robot
killing anybody did it
no um the only thing that happens that
Joanna stabs her friend Bobby after that
Bobby has been Stepford eyes because
she's trying to prove that she's like it
not a human Russ
she just like stabs her and then
Joanna's like what the [ __ ] yeah she
just takes the knife out and then she
starts glitching out like I thought we
were friends I was just gonna make these
ago she starts running around the
kitchen like yeah it's funny because the
robots do glitch out sometimes out in
public and the husband has to make
excuses for something like that I told
you you drinking too much the escorts
are awake she's one of the first things
that like alerted Joanna that something
was weird was that there was like it
when she was at grocery store there's
like a little minor fender bender in the
parking lot and one of the robot wives
I guess she hit her head or something
and then she just kept repeating herself
over and over but then they took her
like they take her out and they say
they're taken to the hospital but Joanna
it's like well you know I didn't think
the hospital was that way but whatever
and then later on there's this garden
party and that woman starts glitching
out she just walks around saying like
I'll just die if I don't get that recipe
yeah I'll just die she like he was
telling everybody that her husband asked
me lately you know yea the husband
excuses like this she was not feeling
well or they drunk yeah it's just like
the cream is taking her medicine and
drinking at the same time something like
that yeah now the interesting thing too
like I said this this seem to have like
a very large cultural impact like you
know much larger than you know it then
you would think they actually made three
sequels to this and a remake which I'm
talking yeah now of the sequels I had
I've seen two of them I saw Revenge of
the Stepford Wives which came out in
1980 that had a very young Don Johnson
in it also had Sharon Gless from Cagney
and Lacey and queer spoke if you watched
that also Julie Kavner who she was the
voice of one of Marge Simpson's sisters
or both of them I can't remember but she
was uh she was uh in this too this was
actually not bad I it's on YouTube for
free if you want it's called revenge of
the Stepford Wives it kind of had a
similar concept where Sharon glass
played a character who was like a
journalist or a report or something like
that and she had heard about Stepford
and it's like oh they have like the
lowest crime of anywhere and it's like
supposed to be this perfect place to
live and she thought that was a little
weird so she was gonna go like check it
out so she wasn't actually moving there
but then she meets like you know Julie
Kavner
actor who is very much the Bobby
character of this movie where she's kind
of like slob and she's kind of like
foul-mouthed funny and [ __ ] like that
you know she actually has a personality
so you know that she's gonna get
Stepford eyes but the weird thing about
this is that it's not really consistent
with the first movie in the first movie
they made it pretty clear that they were
killing the wives and making a robot
replica of them I mean that was the
whole reason why they drew all those
pictures of all her features they
recorded her voice like saying a whole
bunch of different words and [ __ ] like
that but in this one it was more like
they were doing some kind of weird like
brain thing like some brain procedure on
them and then they would keep it going
by they had like these sirens like
really loud sirens that would go like go
throughout the town like four times a
day and then all the women were on
thyroid medication so they had to take
this pill like four times a day so we
can find control more than yeah because
at some point um you know Sharon glasses
characters like the main character who's
investigating all this [ __ ] she actually
is able to snap her friend out of it
which in the original one you wouldn't
have been able to do because the person
was dead they had made you know a
[ __ ] robot out of them so I just
thought that was really weird that they
didn't keep it but I like but I liked
the movie otherwise I had a very similar
it had a lot of similar story beats to
the first one but I just thought that
was weird
there maybe made one also called the
Stepford children which had Barbara Eden
in it that came out in 87 but I haven't
seen that one however I did see the one
that came out in 1996 it was called The
Stepford husbands now that was made for
TV I think it was made for a lifetime if
I'm not mistaken 96 96 yeah it couldn't
be good um it wasn't as bad as I was
expecting I was expecting it to be like
super cheeseball the thing about it
though and this is something that
bothered me was watch I enjoyed it
you know in a cheesy Lifetime movie kind
of way but the conceit doesn't work as
well the other way around you know guys
like Chippendale dancers with damn bow
ties on that's not what they did that
what they did well what they did was
made workers they just work work work
and make money no no no that's not what
they did at all you
this tat like this had like some pretty
famous people like Louise Fletcher was
in it she was like the matriarch of the
town so apparently at some point
Stepford like the women were like [ __ ]
you man were like switching the script
and so basically what they did was they
had the men coming there and you know
these were all like so they had a
women's society that was all like these
high-powered career women you know with
their big shoulder pads and whatnot yeah
yeah they still had shoulder pads then
and basically it didn't work because in
the original Stepford Wives I mean the
whole point was that the guys just
wanted essentially sex pots and maids I
mean and they wanted they didn't want
the woman to have any thoughts of her
own they wanted to be completely
subservient [ __ ] like that but in the
Stepford husband's basically all the
women want and they're not making robots
of them they were just doing some kind
of like mind control cocktail drugs
something like that
all the women wanted was for the dudes
to like help them out around the house
more and like help them watch the kids
and like not be such aggressive [ __ ]
that's all they wanted which seems like
a pretty reasonable like and the thing
about it is that the the main husband at
the center of the thing Mike he's played
by Michael on Cain he was such a douche
like in the beginning of this like he's
like throwing glasses against the wall
it's like he's but you know he's like
this petulant manchild so like the whole
time I was like I could not sympathize
with him because I'm like yes please
pull out his brain sounds like the
series went [ __ ] it's just like I said
it's you know the conceit it was an
enjoyable movie but they can see it
doesn't really work the other way around
have any more extreme it had to be that
guys just go out and make money and
bring the paycheck home you know the
mean and then the wife has boyfriends
and all you know that would be see
that's what I mean it's like it just
seems about watching the kids cuz most
guys that do that anyway that's what I
mean most guys did that anyway back in
the 90s right and that's what I mean so
it's like that's why it didn't seem like
what the women wanted the men to be like
and you know why they were changing them
was not anything unreasonable it's like
oh well I'd actually like my husband to
listen to me when I talk that's like all
they're asking for which is not an
unreasonable thing to ask for it's not
like they were trying to like make them
slaves or anything like that
wanted them to pull their weight so you
know and stop being like like I said
just stop laying around on the couch
drinking beer and watching sports
instead of like helping out you know
what I mean yeah there's a 90s problems
I guess now I want to talk a little bit
about the remake because this was an
abomination unto the Lord and I actually
for some whatever reason I actually paid
money to see this in the [ __ ] theater
dance which is one of the I don't know
why I did well because how could this
how could this have gone well I don't
know and it had like a bunch of famous
people and [ __ ] you know
what's-her-face in the goal Kidman and
that Nicole Kidman was in it Matthew
Broderick doesn't have Bette Midler was
in it and it's like but one it's not a
horror movie it's a comedy okay and it's
a camp comedy it's very over-the-top
yeah they [ __ ] that and it's like why
the [ __ ] would you do that I mean look
this game is that can be done as a
horror movie Jordan Peele did it with
get out this which was basically an
update of The Stepford Wives imagine if
they they like made a horror movie of
like of you know Rosemary's Baby it
wouldn't work
a comedy of comedy Rosemary's Baby yeah
it's just wouldn't work
it's a the thing is you could do a dark
comedy of this but the remake was not it
I mean the remake was just this
ridiculous
kind of like it and and the thing about
it too is that it had these ridiculous
scenes and it was directed by Frank Oz
for Christ's sake who is an awesome
human being but I think even he
regretted it later he's like oh they
just gave me too much money and I just
lost my [ __ ] mind I don't know what I
was doing and a lot of the actors that
were in it were kind of like yeah that
was piece of [ __ ] I wish I hadn't done
it even Matthew Broderick said man I've
been really sad if that was the last
movie I ever did alright but because it
wasn't a fun experience but it had these
[ __ ] crazy scenes like the one scene
like the similar scene where you know
the main character like discovers that
her best friend has been turned into a
Stepford wife Bette Midler was actually
the the friend and she gets stabbed or
something like that and her [ __ ] she
starts glitching out she tears open her
shirt to her bras there she has all
these buttons like this button like
makes her have an orgasm this button
makes her tits bigger like I was and the
did BOTS have remote controls like the
men's have remote
they control the thing and then like her
[ __ ] then her whole chest opens and
there's like beers in there and then
like her head flies off and starts
spinning it's just like the stupidest
thing they did they cut that out of the
movie but I saw it on like another
review like somebody put that in there
because they had the break but the whole
point they missed the whole point of the
original movie too I mean because at the
end you find out that the person behind
Stepford is a woman played by Glenn
Close and she's like oh well I was this
bitter career woman and my husband was
cheating on me with his research
assistant or something like that so I
murdered both of them and turned them
into robots for some reason and then
she's gonna like robot fi everybody it's
like it made no [ __ ] sense at all and
also it had like a happier ending
because Nicole Kidman just pretends to
be Stepford eyes and that it turns out
that her and her husband like conspired
to free all the other women because
again they weren't being turned into
robots necessarily they were just being
like mind controlled so it could be
reversed that sounds like a waste of
time so it was yeah it was a really a
misfire let's is that's the kind of way
that I can say if this movie is actually
the one the original yeah actually it's
pretty good but I would say it's it's
only it's really probably only an
important movie in the context of the
time in which it came yeah if you can
kind of go back to that time period and
think about what it was like if you were
in to say like Westworld
Rosemary's Baby demon seed you'd
probably like this don't legacy this is
a bit like that too it's paced very
similar and Katharine Ross's in it too
like playing the main character so yeah
we're looking for something that's
fast-paced and exciting you know by
modern standards no it's definitely not
it's a slow-paced drama and like I said
I kind of wish that I could see it not
knowing what the secret was because it
would be like a like a creepy like
whodunit because now everybody knows oh
they're all robots I think they knew
they were all robots when the movie came
out even during the trailers so it
didn't it wouldn't have mattered well
live and if you had read the book at you
know three years
so in that was a bestseller yeah because
I think they knew even when it came out
what the movie was about yeah true but
like I said I really did like the slow
build-up of like just just little tiny
weird things like I said like the the
car accident the parking lot it's like
just little weird [ __ ] and it just kind
of like builds up and builds up but you
know like I said I like that ambiguous
thing where it's like she thinks she's
going nuts because she's like maybe this
stuff isn't a big deal maybe I'm
imagining it maybe and then they even go
to like the EPA to like check the water
which is the first thing you would do
cuz they don't like maybe there's
tranquilizers in the water like making
all those women act like this or
anything like that but yeah so go check
it out it's actually free on YouTube
right now as our revenge of The Stepford
Wives and two Stepford husband Stepford
children might be on there see but I
couldn't find it
but I did watch the other two just and
like I said the remake please don't
watch it don't don't give it any money
if I mean if you really want to watch it
then find it for free somewhere a pirate
that should because I don't give anybody
anybody for that [ __ ] thing it was
terrible but yeah so that will do it for
our latest retrospective we will see you
next time bye